au ladakh à rien
[Applaudissements]
3 2 a porté à la douce par là c'est non
c'est plein d'autres mais c'est pas
drôle là préfèrent encore kenny un taxi
basée bas de cycle seras-tu là dessus
vas-y maxime robin et maxime c'est bon
quoi
attends quand on dit maintenant là
c'est quoi ces déchets ont laissé les
cellules et c'est le faire à les y
attend balesi bateau oui
[Musique]
bonjour voilà à la ola la wii jamais il
à basilan l'espagnol mais faut qu'elle
reste à te répondre non non non non il
est pas resté vini vidi d'ivoire allait
vite pas battu à l'aller les mignons et
les boules
il n'a pas commis le ballon vas-y vas-y
ça rappelle que j'ai fait l'armée arrêts
l'armée doit commencer vers cette
semaine c'est pas possible
maxime pas mal mais pas à 100 c'est
mathieu oui vrai ou faux
au pakistan les enfants reçoivent des
paquets cadeaux aux forces armées qu'il
est lourd les amis prenant un peu notre
ami jean mi d'aller faire poser une
pêche ya des pièces tapiès vers le bas
vers un [ __ ] la base de tabac les
allez voir quand même faire invasive
arriver là
allez sans vivant à déconner la dernière
ni flammes et un match c'est pas
possible tu es toi tu promettais comme
toi tais toi et toi aucune recul il
semble en outre mesure sert il
je crois que je vais écouter le pompier
parce qu'il me dit que je suis resté
trop longtemps bravo maxime et messieurs
merci à vous